[band plays national anthem]
(speaker)
It's an honor to be here with
you all on this day
to thank our veterans
to honor their sacrifices.
Many carry
the physical wounds of war
almost all carry
the invisible scars.
They join the service
whole and often
leave pieces of themselves
in these distant lands.
Yet they would never leave
a fallen brother behind.
And they were driven to complete
the mission no matter what.
An Army Ranger chooses this.
He volunteers for it,
fully knowing the hazards
of his chosen profession.
It's not for the money, he makes
not much more than if he chose
a regular nine
to five non-combat job.
It's not for the benefits,
you get the same
if you chose a less hazardous
specialty
It's not for the work
life balance,
He trains for seven months
and deploys for four months
every year, giving up time
with his family and loved ones.
So why does he do it?
He does it for the man to his
left and his right,
to protect his loved ones
back home,
for all of us
civilians stateside right now.
Regardless of whether
you support him or not,
he's willing to sacrifice
everything for you.
Many have given
that ultimate sacrifice
and may they never be forgotten.
To all
the veterans who have served,
thank you for the sacrifices
you've made
and continue to make,
you have given this country
a privilege
that is beyond payment.
We honor you for that today
and every day.
Thank you.
[applause]